my talk at the table we are talking with
an actor who's making his Broadway debut
in a highly anti -anticipated show that
is already folks getting rave reviews
yes Marcel Spears stars as juicy in fat
ham it is a modern reimagining of
Shakespeare's Hamlet the Pulitzer
prize-winning drama adds a few twists to
the classic story fat hand folks is set
at a family Barbecue and centers around
a black gay leading character it's one
of only a few plays to move to Broadway
from a black theater in this clip juicy
gives advice to his friend opal a nod to
Ophelia
okay
you know you don't got to be what your
mama wants you to be that dress that
ain't you what am I supposed
what do you want to do juicy what
girl I can't help what I am I under
yeah
Marcel Spears is here good bro Marcel
Spears Bravo this is this is incredible
this I I've seen the play it's wonderful
this is your Broadway debut it is you've
been an understudy before and I know
that you've talked about like even those
five minutes that you get to shine on
the stage is one that you go home with
for a lifetime what's it like being the
leader yeah it's Indescribable it's kind
of it's kind of like you wake up in a
dream of a thing like you you hope for
it as a Storyteller as an actor you
think like you'll get an opportunity to
do it uh and then when it all happens
you almost can't look at it you got to
focus on the work like I'm just like no
it's just rehearsal for a Broadway show
we're just checking a Broadway show
we're in previews for a Broadway show
and then it's opening night and
everything is like real and you can't
pinch yourself enough
um it feels good it's really validating
uh and I'm glad to be here you should
feel very validated number one I watched
it not knowing what I I didn't read
anything about it so I know it's
interesting yeah so I didn't know what
to expect and the first part you're
saying going what the hell is happening
here it's such a roller coaster of a
show it takes you on so many different
emotions it was a ride I was not
expecting how do you describe this
version compared to Shakespeare's
version how do you describe it
I think like I'm from New Orleans so I
feel like this is like Hamlet with like
a little little hot sauce on like a
little extra like they you know you put
Hamlet like you got a roux and then you
put Hamlet and then you make something
different it's it's really really uh I
feel like if you love Hamlet you will
recognize the the cannon you'll see it
oh it's definitely there you see it it's
present like there's soliloquies that
are really like just ripped out of the
pages but some things are repurposed and
reimagined and sort of restructured in a
new context uh through the lens of
Blackness through the lens of queerness
in in a way that is really really cool
and really exciting and like you said
it's a roller coaster yeah love betrayal
and death the other thing is you were on
stage most of the time yes most of the
time and the audience is like right
where Tony is Tony is closer on the
stage because it's like a back Backyard
Barbecue in the audience to me somehow
becomes part of the play too what's it
like when people are right there in your
face
um I think
I don't know how other actors do but for
me it's a lot of fun is it uh and the
way that the way that our our brilliant
players too James he he wrote the the
fourth wall out of the play like he got
rid of it completely so the audience is
is very much so a part of what we're
doing so I can see you I'm talking to
you like a lot of these asides are are
met just for you
um and for me as an actor I'm like
watching your face in in real time you
are looking at those you are having a
real conversation about everything
that's going on in this in this crazy
play speaking of things in the studio uh
during rehearsals your dog gumbo I have
this right yeah he was there with you
yes okay so I have a new puppy his name
is
oh oh got one of those French Bulldogs
everybody wants one of those bars there
he is yes
um gumbo is is an adorable little dude
uh and he's so young so I take him to to
uh rehearsals with me I'm one of those
guys now I'm one of those actors that
shows up with the dog uh and it was
great because like he plays in between
scenes and he's running around our
director sahi Mali as as brilliant as he
is and as generous as he is
had to ask gumbo to leave rehearsal but
because he's a probably gumbo would
sleep like so it's hard when we're doing
these like really intense emotional
scenes and you hear a French Bulldog
story like a grown man but you're a
theater nerd you actually love to take
sport Shakespeare you perform
Shakespeare so we just want to play a
little game with you is this Shakespeare
or soap opera okay a man tries to scam
two married women out of two married
women out of money by seducing both of
them
so Barbara Shakespeare the merry wives
of Windsor a man dies but is brought
back to life with a serum that when
injected saves life but gives them
amnesia
so Barbara Days of Our Lives yes correct
a woman goes to court disguised as a
male lawyer to defend her friend
Shakespeare oh The Merchant of a minute
and last one a woman dies from drowning
in the same Lake that are farther
drowned in years prior
so Barbara yes The Young and the
Restless
in the beginning as a Shakespeare kid
you felt like it was the theater you
were not invited to yeah what did you
mean I mean I think like just
it doesn't feel like I have access to it
immediately yeah
um the way that it's taught in this
country or the way they used to be
taught I think it's changing now but the
way that it's taught you sort of feel
like it's trying to get you to be
everything that you you are not and um
and so it felt like I was sort of on the
outside I was I was a kid like looking I
couldn't get in the club and I was just
like what's going on with me I like this
work I engage with this work I
understand these emotions
um and then I got some really good
teachers that sort of gave me like the
cheat code to get in and it really is
just owning who you are and bringing all
of that all of your raw materials to the
work well you are soaring in the
neighborhood's on tonight
thank you congratulations uh you can see
Marcela in fat ham on Broadway right now